magnus carlsen took the lead at the 2019
feet a world rapid Chess Championship on
day two in large part because of two
very very key victories I want to show
you both of those games and back-to-back
videos here for chest comms YouTube
channel starting with this victory by
the world champion with the white pieces
over czech republic grandmaster victor
Liz Nika let's dive in so Magnus starts
with d4 and the key thing here is we see
him employee what is a pretty effective
rapid repertoire starting with a London
system now we talk about these system
openings as being effective in faster
time controls because again the the
structures are built on patterns and if
you play a lot of games in those systems
you're gonna get middle games and
tactics that you're more familiar with
than your opponent some of the
disadvantages of course in longer time
control games where your opponent's have
a lot of time to prepare can be that
they they maybe lack some bite right and
that's why you don't see them plain as
often in slower time control events
where players can anticipate it and
really dive in to the best system and
approach as black but you will see it
played a lot in these rapid and blitz
events again because it's it's effective
it's something you can play quickly
knowing that you're in control of the
preparation and your opponent doesn't
really have any surprises coming your
way
so after Knight B to d2 and then Bishop
e7 we see Magnus start the party with
the move 95 now again if we're talking
about effective moves that are showing
that you're in control of the direction
of the game 95 is a good one you're
immediately occupying the most critical
square in the center that you have
control over you're preparing both ideas
common developing moves like Bishop b3
but also putting yourself in a position
where things like g4 and h4 and h5 can
come pretty quickly at the point of
these systems is that if White has the
ability to launch an attack on the King
side with Tempe you're gonna look at
getting black getting in a lot of
trouble so let's Nika does not do this
but just to show an example something
like castles might already be met by g4
and h4 and you might see white really
just throw a ton of material here at the
Kings side even the engines will give
white an edge and this type of thing in
addition to the practical value of
attack
your opponent in a rapid game so because
of that listen II could place the move
h5 to overprotect the g4 square now this
is in theory and novelty h6 is a move
that has been played a game where NIDA
CH German Grand Master had the white
pieces continued with chief four and
then h4 so sort of the same idea I've
been highlighting here with g5 and white
ended up getting a pretty good position
here kind of an all-out type of attack
here Forces black to play f6 because of
the pressure over here on the Kings side
and eventually Knight inch was better in
this position here against Chinese
Grandmaster zone so we back up and just
give you a quick example of maybe yh6
wasn't played less niihka had more
direct intentions in mind to stop the
world champions plans but now we're back
to Bishop III as I said a natural
developing move takes Knight takes
Knight bt7 the Queen comes to e2 which
is flexible here White has not committed
yet to castling long we know that it is
rapid and Magnus might want this type of
attack but the Queen on e2 prepares a
number of things can be preparing f3 and
E for could be preparing to play for c4
the queen is over protecting excuse me
not like a knight she doesn't move that
way but the center here and again you're
also opening the idea of casting long
now after 94 h3 and the trade happened
Bishop d6 Magnus decided to make this
trade and then go ahead and counsel long
I think that white probably has a tiny
edge regardless if you go in for the I
guess longer castling usually associated
with more aggressive intentions
I think White's a little better even if
you Castle short and because of that the
engines kind of say that maybe even just
rooks e1 is a natural way to play this
position as well but from a practical
point of view again I like castles and
now it's sort of forced blacks Han to
play the move h4 the reason he played
this is because let's say you make some
other move I analyzed Queen c7 white can
play g4 and if h4 now you haven't really
stopped me from getting a huge space
advantage over here on the Kings side
and this h4 pawn could eventually become
weak it's a little overextended right
only only getting the protection from
the rook because advancing the pawn
probably not possible so white white
hasn't
positions like this and of course Magnus
could also play similarly to how he did
in the game preparing for F 3 and E 4 so
I like this move castles long black
plays h4 to stop the expansion after a
king to be one Knight f6 here we get the
move about three so the idea here is to
put the Queen on each you try to play
for efore and White's better
strategically in this position just
based on the fact that blacks pawns are
doubled and that white holds the cards
these pawns that are doubled here are
not the weakest double pawns you can
have right we talk about double pawns
being true weaknesses when they're on an
open file when they're isolated right
they're really lacking protection not
just from each other but from other
pieces in a situation like this these
pawns do ctrl-click some critical
squares so I would say the main point to
White's advantage is that white holds
the cards whether I want to play for c4
whether I want to play for
efore maybe I prepare you for what the
rook so that my queen can stay on the
dark squares right the main thing here
is that Magnus got himself a very
flexible position from the start a
position where he was in control of
called the tempo of the game with this
London system there was no preparation
that was gonna surprise him and I think
it was exactly the type of game the
world champion needed to really find his
groove in this day 2 of the world Bratva
championship of course I'm gonna talk a
little bit more about what he did with
his groove in the next video coming your
way to this YouTube channel his victory
over Vietnamese and former world blitz
champion laQuan Liam so that that's
gonna be in the next video but I really
think this was a good game to just set
the Tempe and set the tone that Magnus
was was gonna have a position that he
felt he could push Queen to c7 here
comes the rook to e1 so that when we do
eventually get Eve or the Queen as I
said is on this diagonal here perhaps
with intentions to come over here to the
Queen side to the King side dark squares
Queen to c7 Queen g5 rook T to g8 rook
c1 rook h5 Queen e3 now e5 by black is I
would argue if not if not the mistake in
the game I think from a practical point
of view black is still in it after E 5
but you start to get a feeling that
blacks plan is very disjointed with the
rooks disconnected playing for a move
that like e5 when you're opening the
center
typically you want optimal coordination
right so
we're looking for the educational tip
you can put in your pocket here what's
the what's the takeaway it may be while
is and you could get some trouble here
it is rapid but the point is that when
you when you start to open the center
and you just look at White's pieces here
the rooks coordinated on the e in the C
file right the Queen and Knight
basically helping each other to attack
critical squares within the middle of
the board it's usually not the right
time to try to challenge your opponent
in the most critical area when your
rooks basically aren't coordinating in
the same spots so ii 5 to me when I saw
this move I was like oh right a little
bit a little bit risky they're sitting
on the position asking Magnus what to do
next yes this has been a flexible
opening for you but where you going now
big guy right if you play e5 you can
back up the knight and again you've
maintained a very very solid pawn chain
taking of course it not only brings the
knight but as long as the Brooke is here
might even bring a rook into the center
right so I think there were other things
while I could have done here including
maybe bring this rook over to ca to try
to over protect the area of the board
that Magnus clearly wants to open when
he puts the rook on c1 so I think there
were other things to do here other than
e5 and after he five you see Magnus
strike here this is just the kind of
awareness of what you need to do in a
position that the world champions show
so well right the rooks are disconnected
as I said an open Center more likely
favor white because of that right that's
the educational takeaway so Magnus
decides I'm gonna do just that he takes
and plays c4 really splitting the board
here because the only way for the for
the Chess Republic Grandmaster here to
keep it close is to play a move like d4
which is what he did right but in doing
so he fully commits that this Brooklyn
h5 feels lost right and it really puts
black in a position where he's several
moves away from being able to coordinate
optimally and Magnus takes advantage of
that timing if you play a move like D
takes e4 instead of d4 White has a
number of ways to regain including just
b3 followed by takes and rook over and
even though it's not as closed as it was
in the game the rook is still out of
play
blocked because of the e5 pawn and
Magnus is still very very quickly
opening up the Queen side for for some
play here that is probably gonna take
advantage of blacks uncoordinated rooks
so d4 was played likely just to gain a
tempo to maybe try to give black the
time to
coordinate Queen d2 the knight comes
back to d7 you really love to fill this
square blockade the dark square say I'm
gonna have time to bring my pieces back
around and coordinate but Magnus shakes
that it can't be Mutombo and says no
thank you
you're never gonna use that square again
here after c5 the rook comes to h6 but
here comes before so I just really love
how quickly this game switched right
that it went from kind of poking and
prodding flexible system to really
recognizing how quickly he could open up
the Queen side open up the center and
expose blacks on coordinated rooks and
that's why Magnus is able to go on here
to this very very awesome Queen side
attack slides the Queen over he's
threatening b5 so black stops it but
guess what it's only temporary because
after Queen b3 and the rook comes over
this as soon as I have a chance to get a
four it's coming and that's what Magnus
does followed by b5 followed by more
pieces coming over here to the Queen
side after rook to ca you can pause the
video if you want to find just the kind
of obvious knockout blow but it's time
to calculate buckle up and put this
thing away the move c6 is played of
course black cannot take it twice
because the only way to stop mate would
be Knight b6 which loses a piece so
because of that black played to move
Knight to b6 right away
here comes a5 anyway Knight to a eight
and now we take b7 a little bit of just
kind of smoke here as the guns are
coming out and moves are being played
with Tempe but really this position is
already basically over for black the
knight comes in coming to c5 you give it
to an engine I think white is probably
almost +5 at this point which says
something when it's equal material and
you're up that much Knight to c7 here
comes the knight here comes the pawn
we're gonna do dirty things here along
the a file after b7 check we trade and
now rook to c8 and the sneakin resign so
again start to finish a flexible opening
playing a London system something he
could control the Tempe not be worried
about preparation from his opponent and
feels like he could push on gets a very
flexible middle game where he just waits
for the right time his opponent opening
excuse me opening the center a little
bit too early a little bit
uncharacteristically or let's say a
less-than-ideal when you're Brooks
aren't connected that way Magnus doesn't
need to be asked twice he opens the
position uses the Queen side too
to the to the best possible ability
especially with blacks piece on the
kingside being out of play and needing
time and then execute an attack very
very well so not not the flashiest game
not the most fireworks but I think a
very well executed game by Magnus by the
way moves like rook to b6
well they failed to a number of things
but ba check is is the the biggest
reason and it's probably just some force
checkmate here if you take including
just winning the Queen so anyway just
that was as I was talking everybody that
tactic was in my head I look nice it's
what I do if I take d8 he takes before
we check and then it was b7 if I take b6
he takes at the Queen would check so
sorry the the the chess player me was
kicking in and I had to answer that
final tactic that I didn't prepare
normally I analyze these games beat very
deeply for you all which I did here but
I didn't have that last tactic salt but
anyways just be a queen and you had the
x-ray tactic for both your queen and the
brooke are hitting this square and so it
is game over Red Rover send Magnus
Carlsen right over and please check out
the next video here where I analyze his
victory over laQuan Liam